JEFF DAVIS: Welcome to the
Google Cloud Platform Education
series.
My name is Jeff Davis.
And in this session
we'll discuss
creating best in class
storage solutions
with Google Cloud Storage.
We'll be doing a moderated
Q&A throughout the session,
so feel free to present
your questions in the Ask
Your Question Here field.
Let's get started.
So this is our agenda
for the session.
We're going to begin
with a series of demos.
These are going to highlight the
most typical use cases and just
how easy it is to set up
high-performing, really
functional solutions on top
of Google Cloud Storage.
Out of the demos, we'll
move into a discussion
of the overall GCS
feature set and how
it might apply to challenges
that you're tackling
within your organization.
We'll take a few minutes
to talk about the best
ways to find information
after this session
if you have questions.
And we'll also talk
about how to evaluate
GCS for specific use
cases, specific problems
that you're trying to solve.
And again, throughout
the session,
feel free to submit
your questions.
So on to the demos.
The first use case that
is very typical with GCS
is using it as a target
for offsite backups.
So I'm going to bring up a
piece of backup software.
This is a product
called Retrospect.
There are lots of different
products in this class.
Veritas, for instance,
is a partner with Google
and has their
NetBackup solution.
Lots of solutions will actually
take your onsite backup data
and pump it into
the Cloud, where
you have then an offsite
backup and it can be stored--
large amounts of data for
very small amounts of dollars.
So what we're going
to do is we're
going to start by
configuring the product
so that it will use Google Cloud
Storage as its target location.
So I'm going to
create a mediaset.
And you'll notice that I
have a variety of options.
I'm going to choose to
send it to the Cloud.
We're going to call
this Demo Backup Set.
And we'll go ahead and
encrypt it and give it
a simple password.
Now at this point I'm
prompted for what backend
cloud service I want to use.
And I need to use a
configuration string provided
to me by Google.
So that is Storage API's
GCP webinar backups.
And then I need an access
key and a secret key.
And this is easily configured
within the Google Cloud Storage
user interface.
So I'm going to actually
go to Google Cloud Storage.
This is my project.
I've got a set of buckets.
You'll notice my GCP webinar
backups bucket is here.
I'm going to click on
Settings, Interoperability.
And you'll notice that I
already have some keys created,
so I'm going to actually
use one of these keys.
So I need the access key,
and that's going to go here.
And then I need the secret key,
It uses SSL to
transfer the data.
So it's encrypted in-flight.
And now I have my backup set.
Now I'm going to
actually do a backup.
Retrospect can backup an
individual machine, which
is what I'm going to do here.
It can back up all the
workstations on a network
or it can back up multiple
servers on a network.
So this could be backups
of your internal servers
that are application servers
or file servers, as well as
backups of all of your
important workstation data.
So I'm using this simply
because it's easy to install
and it's relatively
quick to demonstrate.
So I'm going to select
what I want to back up.
And I don't want to back
up my entire hard drive
because we'll be here too long.
Instead what I want to do is I
want to pick a videos folder.
And I back that folder up.
And I'm going to back
it up to the Cloud.
Notice it's a cloud
demo backup set.
And I'm going to run it.
Now, it takes a little while
for this backup job to execute,
so I'm going to go ahead and
let that run in the background
while we move on to the
next part of the demo.
Let's take a look
at performance.
One of the things that
you care about not only
is storing large amounts
of data inexpensively,
but you want to make sure
that your access to that data
is fast and is also reliable.
So again, if I go to my bucket
browser for this project,
you'll notice that I've
got a variety of buckets
other than my backups bucket.
So I have a regional bucket in
the west of the United States,
I have a multi-regional
bucket, and then
I have a Nearline bucket
and a Coldline bucket.
And these are four
different storage classes.
And I'm going to show
you how performance looks
for each one of
these, and then we'll
talk about the differences
in a little bit.
So in order to test performance
across a variety of areas,
I've actually created a
bunch of test instances.
So you'll notice that I've
got virtual machines running
in different parts of the world.
So I've got one in
Asia, I've got one
on the East Coast which
is not in the same region
as my regional
bucket, I've got one
on the West Coast which
is in the same region
as my regional bucket, and
I've got one in Europe.
So what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to SSH into each of
these virtual machines
so that I can generate
load against GCS.
So let me shrink
that window down.
Notice my backup is still
running in the background,
so I'm going to shrink
that down as well.
And what I have here
is four SSH windows--
one to each of my
different machines.
So I'm going to
use a cURL command.
cURL is a command that basically
is going to do a URL request.
The items that I'm
pulling out of the buckets
have actually been made
publicly accessible
and can be accessed
using a standard URL.
So what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to copy down a relatively big
file from a regional bucket.
So this bucket is stored
in the West Coast.
And what we really want to
see is, is it fast, man?
Can I pull down big
files really quickly?
So I'm going to go ahead
and enter this command
in each of the windows.
And what this should do
is start a file download
from four different instances
in four different regions.
And what we want to see is, what
does the performance look like?
So if I look at the
instance in the West,
you can see I'm averaging 292
megabytes per second download.
That's pretty quick.
If I look in the East
of the United States,
it's about 314 megabytes-- so
roughly the same performance.
If I look in EMEA,
it's 203 megabytes.
And this is because the client
that's running in Europe
is accessing resources stored
in a Western region bucket.
That means that it
is not connected
with the same high throughput
low latency connections
that, say, this instance
in the West Coast is.
So relatively quick.
We averaged-- it looks like--
96 megabytes per
second in Europe.
We averaged 85 megabytes per
second in the East Coast.
We managed about 100
megabytes per second.
And in Asia, about 92.
So pretty good performance
around the globe from data
that's stored in the Western
part of the United States.
I'm going to do the
same thing, except I'm
going to copy this not from
my Western regional bucket,
but instead from a
multi-regional bucket.
So a multi-regional
bucket is a bucket
where your data is
actually replicated,
not just in the Western United
States, but in the Central
and in the Eastern
United States as well.
What this means
is that it's going
to be closer to a
wider range of clients.
So again, I'm
going to copy this.
And we're going to
start it in Asia
and then we're going
to go to Europe
and then we're going to go
to the Western United States.
And there was one more in there.
There's the East.
And you can see that the
multi-regional bucket
is even faster.
So again, we're at
roughly a gigabyte
per second in the West.
In EMEA, we're at
about 500 megabytes.
In the East, we're
at about a gigabyte.
And in Asia Pacific,
we're at about 413.
So again, multi-regional
buckets are even faster
than the regional buckets.
Now I'm going to do
a small file from
the multi-regional buckets.
And this is important
for the next test,
which is the Nearline test.
So what I want to
do is I want to see
if you download this small
file, how fast is it?
And again, super fast.
Super fast.
Now, Nearline, as you may know--
Nearline is a less
expensive storage class
that's intended for data that
isn't accessed that frequently.
So they move it a
little bit further away
from the standard access points.
It means that you
can access it, but it
is going to cost you
every time you read it.
We'll talk about the
pricing in just a second.
But what I want to show you here
is even though you've moved it
to a tiered storage
offering, it doesn't actually
slow down the speed with which
you can access or download
the files.
So here we go.
You'll notice from Nearline,
I'm still seeing 652 megabytes.
I'm seeing 440 megabytes.
I'm seeing 761 megabytes.
I'm seeing 380 megabytes.
Notice access time was tens
or hundreds of milliseconds.
It was really quick.
And it was the same
command to access it
from Nearline as from a regional
or multi-regional bucket.
Now let's go a step further.
Let's go to Coldline.
So Coldline is even
less expensive.
It's intended for data that you
only access very infrequently.
But again, use the same
access mechanisms and you
get the same retrieval speeds
as you do from standard buckets.
So you'll notice
413, 778, 511, 929.
So even though you've
moved to tiered storage
and you've gone from regional
to Nearline to Coldline storage,
you haven't had to sacrifice
initial access time or download
throughput or change
the APIs that you use.
This is a big plus relative
to some other solutions
that are available to you.
In the meantime, let me go back
and check the backup software.
You can see that the
backup is actually running.
We'll take a look when it's
done to see that it's actually
stored the stuff in the bucket.
So we've got backup
running, we've
just showed performance and
the relative performance
of a multi-regional bucket
versus a regional bucket
versus Nearline versus Coldline.
So now let's take a look
at a couple of other things
that you can do.
So one frequent use of
Google Cloud Storage
is to store large media objects
for serving on websites.
So here we have an example
learning management system
that's got videos embedded in
their micro learning lessons.
And you can see this module
is all about the fact
that mantas are awesome.
This is a video that
I took while diving
with mantas off of Kona.
If I load this page, you can see
that it actually is streaming
the video to my machine.
Now, this video is stored
in Google Cloud Storage.
And in fact, if we go
to the Cloud Storage
UI, what you can see is here
is a bucket for that project.
And this bucket has
got a couple of copies
of the mantas
streaming video file.
It has a bunch of
other ones as well.
So what happens is you
set up your web server
and it simply proxies
these media files.
You can see that these
files are shared publicly
and there's a
public link option.
If you click on the public link,
this actually gives you a URL
and you can serve the
video directly from GCS.
There's me talking
about something else.
So this is a very
common application,
and it's super, super easy.
You just upload your files,
you click on Share Publicly,
and you get a link
that you can then
publish within your web pages.
So let me close
those two windows.
I'm going to check on my
backup and see how we're doing.
It's still thinking about it.
So I'm going to
let that continue
to bake in the background.
It's going to go into the
webinar backups bucket.
And you can see that there
is a demo backup set.
And this is where the
backup is occurring.
It's not done yet, but
it's backing stuff up.
Let's look at
another application.
So GCS is a really good
place to stage data
that you are moving into or
out of data analytics jobs.
So here's an example of
a big analytics table
that I use for a customer
success application
that I've built.
So you can see that this
is a BigQuery table.
It It's not that big.
It has 525,000 rows.
There are obviously
much bigger ones
if you look at the
BigQuery samples.
You can go to the
Wikipedia benchmark
and you'll see that they've
got one million rows, one
billion rows, 100 billion rows.
So that makes my little
dataset look paltry actually.
But 525,000 rows would be
a lot to write row by row.
So instead what we want
to do is we actually
want to import this data.
And the easiest way to import
it is you upload it to GCS,
and then GCS has a really easy
integration with BigQuery.
So if you look, here's a bucket.
This is the bucket associated
with the success HQ software.
That's the customer
success platform.
Again, it's not a huge file,
but it's a 48 megabyte file.
And this has got
the 525,000 rows.
Think of it as being
500 million rows.
Again, you just upload
it to the bucket.
And then in BigQuery, if
you want to import it,
you simply say, I want
to create a new table.
And you say, I want
to choose a file.
Actually, I don't
want a file upload.
I want to do Google
Cloud Storage.
And then you need
the path to the file.
So that's going to be in the--
let's see.
Yes.
GS colon slash slash
shq transfer slash--
and then the name
of the file is this.
And then I could specify
the schema explicitly.
I'm going to actually
have BigQuery
try to automatically detect it.
And I'm going to give it
a demo events table name
and create a table.
And this then inserts
a job, and it's
going to import the CSV file
from Google Cloud Storage.
It'll take-- if I'm not lying--
about five more seconds.
And it should be done.
You'll notice here we've got the
entries showing that the demo
events table is loading.
Oh, there we go.
We're done.
So you'll notice it's
created fields for each one.
In Details, you
can see that we've
imported 522,000 some odd rows.
And if I want to see
that this data is,
in fact, live, what
I can do is I can--
let's see, shrink this down
a little bit, pick this,
and I'm going to do Select star
from events.demo events table.
So let's run the query.
And if all goes well, we should
see I get all of the event data
that's recorded by my
customer success system.
And I have 522,000 rows.
So again, that took
about 10 to 15 seconds.
If you extrapolate that--
so if you go to 500 million,
it's still a relatively
quick import.
And again, this is using
GCS as a staging mechanism
for getting data into
BigQuery or into Dataflow
or into Dataproc.
It's also a great target
repository for GPC services.
So any of those big
data analytics tools
can actually dump the data
into Google Cloud Storage,
and then you can actually
share this with other folks.
Let's switch back to my backup.
And it looks like my backup
is actually complete.
So if I go to the
backup bucket, I
should now have a
full demo backup set.
And this was about
a gigabyte of data.
So you can see there's a 600
meg file and a 420 meg file.
I had about a gigabyte
worth of videos that I
uploaded relatively quickly.
So what we've got here
is examples of a variety
of different applications.
We have files that are
just stored for download.
This might be
appropriate, for instance,
if you're a software company
and you're distributing
your application and you want
to make sure people can download
the application and that
it's highly available
and a good download performance.
We did backups, where
we took large amounts--
in this case, only a
gigabyte-- but, again,
if you do this across
a bunch of machines,
you would take all of that
data and you would pump it up
to the Cloud.
And then you could actually
store these backups
in various tiers of storage.
So old backups, you could
have in Coldline and so forth.
And we talked about serving
media in web applications
and we talked about using
GCS as a staging area
for getting data in and out of
big data analytics pipelines.
Hopefully you've seen at
least one or two things
here that really gets
you excited and curious
as to how you can leverage
GCS for your company.
So let's switch back
to the presentation
and let's talk at a high
level about the wide range
of capabilities and
the pricing information
about Cloud Storage.
So again, Cloud Storage is
a unified storage product
that runs atop of Google's
massive storage and networking
infrastructure.
It is BLOB storage, or
Binary Large Object storage.
This is not a
regular file system
where you're reading and writing
and updating data within files.
This is where you store lots
of files that are relatively
static and you read them
periodically for analysis
or you just keep
them in archival.
And they feed into things
like live data serving
or analytics, that
sort of stuff.
You have one consistent
API to access
all of the different
types of storage.
You have similar latency
and download speeds
across those
classes, which makes
it super easy to work with.
So here's a slide
that we're going
to spend a little time on.
This details the four
different storage classes
and their differences
within Google Cloud Storage.
So the one that most people
start with is regional storage.
And remember, in
Google Cloud Platform,
a region is a
collection of resources
that are interconnected with
high-throughput, low-latency
network connections.
That means that an
instance in the West region
can read and write data to a GCS
bucket in the West region very,
very quickly.
Your data-- when you write it
into Google Cloud Storage--
is actually replicated across
machines throughout the region.
What this means is you have
very, very high durability
and very high availability.
The likelihood that you
are going to lose data
is extremely low, because
even if a particular storage
device drops out, your
data is replicated.
Even if a zone
goes out, your data
is replicated across other
zones within the region.
Your data is also
highly available,
which means that, again,
if a zone goes down,
you'll have live
copies of your data
in another zone
within the same region
and you can access it there.
Then people sort of
move to multi-regional.
Multi-regional is where
you have resources
that are holding your data.
And they're not just
spread out within a region,
they're actually spread
out through what's
called a multi-regional area.
So there are three
multi-regional areas
in Google Cloud Platform.
There's a North
American, or a US region,
there's an EMEA, and
an Asia Pacific region.
So this gives you even higher
levels of availability.
If the Western
region goes down, you
can still read your
data from the Central
or the Eastern region.
So you can see actually
that the availability
is better with multi-regional
as opposed to regional.
You also get a
performance improvement,
in that because your data
is in multiple locations
throughout the
United States, it's
more likely that any given user
will be closer to that data.
On the right-hand
side then, you have
Nearline and Coldline storage.
And these are intended to
hold data at reduced costs,
but it's data that you
don't access as often.
So basically what happens is if
you put something in Nearline,
Google essentially
puts it someplace
that it's less expensive
for Google to store,
but it's more expensive
for Google to serve.
So what they do is they
cut the price for storage,
but then they make you
pay for accessing it.
You don't pay a
performance penalty,
you still have access times
in tens of milliseconds
and you still have
high throughput,
but they have to go
through more contortions
to serve the data at that speed.
Therefore while it
costs less to store,
it actually costs
more to access.
So it's really good if you
access this data infrequently.
So at the top here, we
show this is intended
for data that is frequently
accessed across regions,
within a region, accessed
less than once a month,
or accessed less
than once a year.
Durability is a lot of nines.
Availability-- the worst-case
scenario is 1% of the time,
you might not be able to access
your Nearline or Coldline
data at a given point in time.
And it's three
nines for regional
and it's three nines and
a five for multi-regional.
You use the same
APIs or the same GUI
or the same command
line utilities
for getting data in and out of
all of these storage classes.
You have the same
latency for reads.
The difference here is on cost.
So at the top end--
the top shelf multi-regional
storage class--
you pay $0.026 per
gigabyte per month.
For regional, you
get a discount.
You pay $0.02 per
gigabyte per month.
Nearline, you pay half that.
You pay $0.01 per
gigabyte per month.
What's interesting,
though, is you
pay roughly $0.01 per gigabyte
to read the data off the disk.
So if you read the data once
a month, you about break even.
If you read the data
once every three months,
you're clearly going to come
out ahead versus regional.
If you read the data
three times a month,
you would actually
pay more for Nearline
than you did for regional.
And then Coldline,
you pay 7/10 of a cent
per gigabyte per month, but
you pay a higher access charge.
Now, storage, when it
comes to the cost entailed
in Google Cloud Storage, you
pay this ongoing storage fee.
Then for Nearline and
Coldline, you pay to access--
or read-- the data off the disk.
And then you also pay for
what's called network egress.
So that is any data that
leaves the region where
the data is stored, you
end up having to pay.
The lowest price is about
$0.08 per terabyte transfer.
Now, again, if you're
using a regional bucket
and your server is
in the West region
and it's reading and writing
to a cloud bucket that's
in the West region, it never
leaves the West region data
centers, therefore you
don't pay network egress.
But for instance, with that
learning management system
with the little
video lesson, I'm
paying $0.02 per gigabyte
per month to store it.
And then every time somebody
loads that page, the data
is leaving the data
center, and so I'm
having to pay between
$0.08 and $0.11
per terabyte of
storage transferred out
of the data center.
All in all, far less
expensive than building
the same type of
infrastructure on premise--
also far more secure,
far more reliable.
Speaking of security,
you can rely on not only
Google's hardware
infrastructure,
but on their software and
processes, to secure your data.
So Google has
invested huge amounts
of money developing processes,
technical talent, and software
that keeps its data secure.
So they run at least a half
dozen applications that
have a billion active users.
Those need to be secure.
And they're
basically leasing you
space on their infrastructure.
So for instance, all
your data is encrypted.
Google automatically
encrypts the data.
They hold the encryption keys
and rotate those encryption
keys on a well-documented basis.
If you work in an industry where
you have to manage the keys,
you can use GCS with
customer-supplied encryption
keys.
IAM is Identity and
Access Management.
This is a mechanism
that you use to control
who can do what to which
resources in your GCS projects.
And the same permissioning
scheme and authentication
system that you use to manage
access to Compute Engine
instances or to
BigQuery tables, you
can use to control access
to buckets and objects
within your project.
In addition to that--
so, for instance,
editors on your project
can read and write
to all of your
buckets by default.
But let's say you have a
particular bucket that you
don't want every editor on
your project to have access to,
only a very few particular
people should have access.
You have an additional
layer of security,
which is access control lists.
And those access control lists
can be set at the bucket level
and you can have
default permissions set
for every object inside, or
you can manually and explicitly
set access control lists
on individual objects.
In some cases, you want
to make access to objects
within a bucket
available to people
who don't have Google accounts.
So one thing about IAM
is it requires the person
to whom you're granting roles
to have a Google account.
In a lot of cases, you
are serving up media
and you may want to serve that
to the public, in which case
you set a special ACL that says
it's available to everyone.
But in other cases
you don't want
it to be publicly
available, you want
to secure it for
particular individuals
but you can't guarantee
that those individuals have
Google accounts.
So there are code libraries
available for developers
to create what are
called Signed URLs.
And these URLs basically
have an indication
of what a person can do to
a given resource in GCS,
how long that
permission is granted.
And then anybody who holds
that URL can actually
access without having
a Google account.
So this is not
unlike those password
reset verification emails,
where it goes to your email
and it gives you a big
long arbitrary link
and if you click on that then
you can reset your password.
And having that link
is your permission
to reset your password and it's
only good for a certain period
of time.
This is similar in concept.
And for those of you who develop
mobile applications using
the Firebase mobile
development framework,
Firebase actually has their own
storage security rules system
which makes it really
easy for developers
to create security rules
without having to worry
about the particulars of GCS.
And they apply directly
to GCS on your behalf.
Ways to get data in to
Google Cloud Storage.
So there are simple ways,
there are interactive ways.
So you can go through the GUI
and click a button and upload
a file.
You can use the
gsutil utility to copy
a file from your local machine.
But obviously if you're doing
large quantities of files
or maybe really 10
100-terabyte files,
doing sort of an interactive
session from your local machine
probably doesn't
make a lot of sense.
Other ways to get data
in include integrations
with other GCP services.
So for instance, I showed
you the BigQuery integration.
You can just as easily
dump a huge BigQuery
table or the results
of a big data process,
you can dump that all out
into Google Cloud Storage
very easily.
There are third-party
integrations,
and the Retrospect
software that I showed
you was an example of that.
That is third-party backup
software that writes data
directly into the Cloud.
For really large
volumes of data,
you might go with a
third-party service
or a third-party appliance.
So companies like
Zadara basically
create appliances
that they put on-prem
and they act as
bridges, where they
pull huge amounts
of on-prem data
and they pump them through very
high-speed network connections
up into the Cloud.
And then third-party
services would
be something like Iron Mountain,
who will actually come to you,
pick up a bunch of your
media, take it offsite,
and upload it to
the Cloud for you.
Getting data out-- sort
of the reverse process.
So again, you can
do it interactively.
So you can just click on a
link and download a file.
You can use gsutil to copy
files out of the Cloud
onto an on-prem device.
Again, data can go out of
GCS into other Google Cloud
Platform services very easily.
We showed that with BigQuery.
The LMS system
that I showed you,
where you had that little
video module about mantas,
that's using proxy web access.
So basically you hit a web
server, and the web server--
when it sees a URL pointing to
a Google Cloud Storage URL--
it will proxy-- it'll
grab the data out of GCS--
and then serve it up.
Or you can even serve
files directly out of GCS.
So I showed you where
the public links are.
If you click on that link, GCS
actually acts as a web server,
so you can upload a
bunch of static files
and run a web server
out of GCS without
any additional software.
To manage your data--
I've already highlighted
this a couple of times--
you have a consistent
set of APIs
that you can use across
all the storage classes.
There are also some
really cool features
that make it easier to keep
just the right amount of data
and just the right
versions of data.
So for instance, there's
Lifecycle Management.
What this allows you to do
is say, hey, any files that
are older than 365 days, I
want to move them into Nearline
from regional.
So I actually want to move them
into a different storage class,
and therefore I
get to save money.
Or I want to only
keep the latest
three versions of
a particular file
and throw away anything
older than that.
So you set these as
little JSON snippets.
They describe what a particular
bucket or object does,
in terms of
lifecycle management,
and then the system
takes care of it for you.
Speaking of versioning, there
is object versioning within GCS.
And what this allows you to
do is basically say, when
you overwrite an existing
object with a new object,
it keeps the previous version.
And so you can override it
over and over and over again
and have lots of different
versions of the same object.
And then at any time, you
can list those versions
and you can actually
recover a version that
has been previously stored.
Now, obviously, you
have to pay for all
these multiple versions,
so that stacks up.
And that's why you combine
it with Lifecycle Management
to maybe age out and only
keep the last three versions.
An object change
notification is a feature
where you can have a bucket
notify an external application
every time a new object gets
dropped into the bucket,
for instance.
So let's say you had an
application where users
uploaded photos, and every
time a photo got uploaded,
you wanted to actually
create a thumbnail.
So you wanted a service
to open the image,
shrink it down, and save
the thumbnail in a database,
for instance.
What you would do is you
would configure object change
notification on the bucket.
Every time a new file gets
uploaded, a webhook fires,
talks to your
server application,
that then responds by
creating the thumbnail.
So given all these
capabilities, you
want to start
thinking about, where
can we leverage Cloud
Storage to solve
problems for our business?
One example here is the
Autism Speaks project.
So what Autism
Speaks wanted to do
was create a really
large shared dataset
about genomic information
related to autism.
So every sequenced genome takes
up to 200 gigabytes of data.
They started by sequencing
roughly 1,300 genomes,
so this created over
100 terabytes of data.
Now, 100 terabytes of data
doesn't seem that large,
but, remember, the target
wasn't just these 1,300,
they wanted to have
10,000 plus people who
had their genomes sequenced.
And now you're talking
multiple petabytes of data.
That's a significant
amount of data.
Where can you store
this data so that you
can control who
has access to it,
you can host it
relatively inexpensively,
and it has high-performance
downloads around the world?
Well, they did it on Google
Cloud Platform using GCS.
So they ended up creating
this dataset that
could be used by the best
scientists in the world
to run analyses against
trillions of data points
to try to find new ways
of addressing autism
in individuals.
You may not have
something quite this big
or you may have something
actually bigger.
In any case, GCS probably
will work really well for you.
Now, after this session, if
you come up with questions
and you want to learn
more about Cloud Storage,
where do you look?
Search is your friend.
If you search on
Google Cloud Storage
and then whatever topic
you're interested in,
it's very likely
that the first link
is going to be what you want.
So for example, here we've
searched on Google Cloud
Storage classes
and what we get is
a link to the article that
has all the information that
fed the table that
we looked at earlier.
If you're trying to figure
out the right command line
structure for doing things
using the gsutil utility,
type in gsutil and
then the action
that you want to perform.
So like gsutil copy or
gsutil move or gsutil rename.
Again, like every
other GCP project,
the Google Cloud Storage
documentation at the top level
has got this nice six sections.
It's got a quick start, it's
got a series of how-to guides,
such as how to create buckets,
how to upload or download
files, how to
create signed URLs.
Then it has deep dives into
the APIs and general concepts.
It has tutorials
and other resources,
including the pricing
information and link
to a pricing calculator,
which you can use to predict
what your costs will be.
Some things to
consider as you're
evaluating applying Google Cloud
Storage to particular use cases
in your organization.
Again, have a process
and be methodical.
It's not hard, but
do a good job of it.
Figure out what it is that
you need to know in order
to determine if GCS is
appropriate for the use cases
you're thinking about.
Figure out what you
need to test and what
your acceptance threshold is.
So for instance, we need
to know that we get x kind
of performance in
Australia or we
need to know that we can
keep our monthly budget
below a certain level.
Then figure out how you're
going to do the testing.
So you need to figure out how
many buckets, how many objects,
how much data, what
kind of integrations
you're going to use with
third-party products,
and so forth.
And do a little bit of
research to figure out how
you're going to implement it.
And then figure out who's
going to participate.
Somebody probably is going
to architect the solution,
somebody is going to be
responsible for setting it
up and operating it.
And then somebody is project
managing the whole process,
collecting the results,
analyzing the results.
And then, obviously,
your business leaders
will be making a decision.
Again, timelines,
you can typically
do one use case within a month.
Often it can be
faster than that,
although it depends on how
complex the solution is.
Typically, you break this
down into one segment
that's about defining your
criteria, recruiting your team,
and agreeing on
what you're testing.
A second segment,
which is figuring out
how you're going to test--
this is generally some
point testing and some trial
and error and some research.
And then, ultimately,
you perform your tests,
you collect your data, and
you analyze the results
and you make a decision.
If you put more
people against this,
you can get more
use cases tested out
in the same time line.
If it's a really
sophisticated solution,
it may take you a
little bit longer.
But hopefully this
gives you a sense
of how to tackle the
evaluation of GCS
as an appropriate technology
for your use cases.
And that's it for this session.
Thanks so much for joining us.
I hope you learned something
and that you enjoyed it.
We'll be sending you
a followup email that
has a link to a code lab, where
you can get your hands dirty
and try GCS out for yourself.
We'd love your feedback, so make
sure to provide that on screen.
And stay tuned for
our next session.